traditionnement les journaux télévisés
ne s'intéresse à l'actualité
cinématographique après le développement
d'une actualité souvent tragiques et
chaude
nous avons choisi de déroger à la règle
pour évoquer tout de suite l'hommage que
vient de rendre hollywood à jeanne
moreau
c'est un oscar d'honneur qui a été
décerné la nuit dernière à l'actrice
française dans la capitale mondiale du
cinéma sur place le reportage à nicole
cornu langlois et jean louis normandin
ces moments d'émotion entre deux stars
fut l'un des moments forts de l'hommage
rendu par l'académie des arts de los
angeles à jeanne moreau
pour ses 50 ans de carrière trois femmes
avant elle avait eu cet honneur mais à
titre posthume louise renner anna
magnani marlene dietrich
entouré de ses amis jeanne relativement
calme prépare cet événement se veut
rigoureux elle essaie de comprendre ce
que les américains apprécient en elle
j'aime les gens qui osent faire des
choses initier des choses
j'aime les débuts et on peut être
débutant toute sa vie on peut faire des
choses pour la première fois toute sa
vie c'est même pas une question d'âge
cette cérémonie c'était la
reconnaissance du tout-hollywood de
grands réalisateurs ou de grands
producteurs comme ismaël mercante ou des
actrices françaises ou américaines comme
sharon stone qui présentait cette soirée
pour elle she's my printemps elle est
mon ami
amen elle est un modèle elle est de ma
planète
si sages disent si digne profonde et
spécialement performant
une des raisons voulait gâcher devient
actrice
important quel film vous avez le plus
impressionné belle
j'ai beaucoup géré jir du lait gym ce
fut l'un des 20 films internationaux
dont les extraits montrèrent la
diversité de son talent mais aussi de sa
sensibilité
à leszno
programme plus qu'un hommage figé ce que
tu une fête chaleureuse de l'amitié et
de la générosité